en direct de kiev notre correspondant
gulliver cra gulliver bonjour vous suez
pour nous cette séquence en portant une
visite d'un représentant français
catherine colonna qui est la plus haute
représentante française à rendre visite
aux ukrainiens depuis le début de la
guerre c'est arrivé était attendu
oui en ce moment la ministre est en
train de s'entretenir avec son homologue
ukrainien dmitro couler bas dont le
ministère des affaires étrangères
ukrainienne qui est derrière moi on
attend de voir quels seront leurs
déclarations après cette rencontre pour
les ukrainiens il y a deux objectifs
principaux je pense avec tous les alliés
occidentaux qui viennent de l'union
européenne c'est d'abord d'obtenir plus
de livraisons d'armes la france a déjà
livré dès 8h de type césar à l'ukraine
qui sont en action déjà sur le front
dans l'est dans le dôme bas c'est hier
les militaires ukrainiens ont communiqué
qu' ils ont pu à l'aide de ces 1/8 sert
à détruire cinq véhicules militaires
russes donc les ukrainiens savent
utiliser ses auditeurs c'est ce qu'ils
ont souligné et il voudrait que la
france envoie plus d'armes lourdes et la
deuxième objectif c'est d'obtenir
l'appui de la france à la candidature de
l'ukraine à rejoindre l'union européenne
à la fin du mois de juin l'ukraine
espère obtenir le statut de candidat
pour le moment les déclarations des
dirigeants français vont plutôt dans
l'idée de mettre un frein ou de moins de
rire si vous voulez les espérances des
ukrainiens en ce sens sont disons que
cela prendra des années avant que
l'ukraine puisse accéder à l'union
européenne les ukrainiens leur tâche est
vraiment d'essayer de convaincre des
pays réticents comme la france de
changer de position est appuyée comme
c'est le cas par exemple de la pologne
les pays baltes une
une adhésion accélérée pour l'ukraine au
bloc on va suivre à vos côtés tout à
l'heure en direct donc la conférence de
presse de la chef de la diplomatie
française gulliver en a déjà entendu
cette première réaction à abuja
l'expression de la solidarité des
français envers le peuple ukrainien on
le sait qu'il y aura d'autres dossiers
également évoqué la crise alimentaire
qui qui se profile et qui sera aussi
abordée à bruxelles aujourd'hui lors du
sommet européen
ça c'est aussi bien sûr quelque chose
qui concerne beaucoup la france où la
france a très envie d' aider l'ukraine à
trouver le moyen d'exporter ses produits
alimentaires pour le moment il y a des
montagnes et de grains dans les ports
ukrainiens qui ne peuvent pas être
exportés de céréales parce que les ports
maritimes de l'ukraine sont tous bloqués
par la russie pour le moment le seul
moyen d'exporter c'est par la voie
ferrée par la route et un tout petit peu
par aussi la voie fluviale sur le danube
dont l'extrême sud ouest de l'ukraine
mais les capacités pour le moment de ces
voies alternatives d'exportation sont
plus de multiples fois moindre que
l'exportation maritime mais pour le
moment le déblocage de ces ports
maritimes par la russie ne semble pas du
tout possible puisque la russie réclame
la levée des sanctions comme une sorte
de
deux conditions pour lever le blocage
des ports ukrainiens et bien sûr c'est
une condition qui n'est pas acceptable
ni pour l'ukraine ni pour ses
partenaires parce que cela s'apparente à
une forme de chantage
merci beaucoup bu l'hiver cra